[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes heureux du succès de cette
première journée avec ma plateforme qui
a réalisé la centrale supélec première
journée dédiée aux quatre formes
technologiques de sciences de la vie que
j'ai nopal organisé depuis cinq années
consécutives et fort de cette expérience
nous nous sommes rapprochés du
département sciences de la vie de
l'université paris saclay pour mettre en
place cette journée qui est dédié donc
aux plateformes technologiques dans le
domaine des sciences de la vie et
notamment pour créer des interactions
entre les académiques et les industriels
une plateforme technologique c'est le
regroupement un endroit unique de
compétences savoir faire et
d'équipements à la pointe de la
technologie dans le domaine des sciences
de la vie
[Musique]
ce département regroupe aujourd'hui 200
plateforme technologique un grand nombre
sont affiliés à des organismes de
recherche certaines au genopole le
programme de la journée comprend
plusieurs actes le premier acte était
d'une introduction faite par le
directeur du département sciences de la
vie puis par un acteur du génopole le
deuxième acte était une table ronde où
trois industriels renommée est bien
connu 2
l'industriel se sont présentés servier
danone est hantée rome l'acte iii était
une présentation des typologies des plus
importantes de ces plateformes comme
l'imagerie ou la génomique et le
quatrième acte est ce que vous voyez
derrière moi savoir tous ces stands avec
84 plateforme présente des industriels
présents cet après midi on laisse la
place aux plateformes technologiques
pour qu'elles puissent rencontrer les
autres plates formes du territoire
qu'elles puissent créer une vraie
communauté sur paris saclay des
plateformes sciences de la vie et on
invite également des industriels à venir
les rencontrer pour ouvrir un peu ces
plateformes est donné
accès à leur expertise à ses industriels
donc on a plus de 30 sont présents
aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui c'est libre cours à ses
plateformes en espérant que les échanges
soient productifs nous en tout cas côté
université paris saclay genopole on n'en
doute pas et on est très fiers
d'accueillir tout ce monde aujourd'hui
[Musique]